spring break is coming up ted's excited
too for spring break but this saturday
notes with a purpose takes over the las
vegas natural history museum with an
interactive musical scavenger hunt the
carnival cavalcade of cannabis creatures
here to tell us more is dr alexandra lee
who is with notes with a purpose and
aiden newman who will be performing the
double bass this weekend hello you two
hi hi thanks for joining us oh it's
great to be here thanks for having us
okay tell us more what's happening
saturday what's happening this weekend
okay so musicians are strategically
placed around the las vegas natural
history museum and it's our guest's job
to find all the musicians
who are hiding around the museum
with a treasure map that is beautifully
hand illustrated they're going to find
people musicians like aiden here
who are going to be in a corresponding
gallery to the role that they're playing
inside the music
so for example aiden here is playing the
double bass and he will be in the
prehistoric mammals gallery
yeah i'll go on i'll be in the
prehistoric mammals gallery with a uh
the skull of an ancient elephant um i'll
be there playing the base there'll be a
little cave bear there as well it should
be it should be very interesting this is
an amazing event has this happened
before is this the first time you guys
are doing this this is not only the
first time we're doing this but any type
of museum music interaction with
carnival of the animals it's a beloved
long uh
everyone loves uh this classical music
piece that's perfect for children
so um no one else has ever done this
before well i like it too because as a
child for me i wasn't introduced to
classical music this is a great way to
introduce kids to classical music now
when the scavenger hunt is all said and
done what happens afterwards you guys
get together for a big performance yup
they gather outside uh for a full
performance of carnival of the animals
and it's written by a french composer
camille seissant and it is and it's and
it's music that we've heard it's been
integrated into pulp cult pop culture so
it's going to be very fun aiden how long
have you been performing uh pretty much
half my life so i guess at this point
that would be just about eight nine ten
years something like that you're a long
time yeah long time yeah over there
people that want to go this weekend how
long is everything gonna take how long
should we carve out for this weekend two
hours and is it is it is it throughout
the day is it starts at ten what time
does it start either two sessions one
starts at 10 am and the other at 1 pm it
is free for anyone under 18 years old we
really want to make this as accessible
as possible
children will be able to see musicians
that are just as near their age like
aiden so they can be inspired
by by musicians who grew up in this
community as well and so how do people
get tickets they go to the las vegas
natural history museum's website which
is www.lvnhm.org
perfect aidan are you ready to give us a
little taste yes of course okay the
stage is yours we'll step out and take
it away my friend
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]